emmanuel sanders had his press
conference on friday he's joined the
buffalo bills we had a story at pft how
he'd been watching the bills the bills
have been watching him he's intrigued by
the fact that josh allen is there to
throw
60-yard lasers down the field and
if josh allen for some reason is unable
to play their backup this year a guy
named
mitchell trubisky the second overall
pick in 2017. here's brandon being the
gm of the bills
on the decision to bring in trubisky as
the backup to josh allen
this is a reset for him and we don't
expect him to be here long term this is
a
kind of a one year probably not in his
plans
uh when he was drafted where he was but
we hope it's a great reset
for him sean uses it you know make you
be you know the best version of yourself
here in buffalo and then you know
hopefully in a year
he'll get a chance to go back and and
land
a nice contract and a starting job
somewhere
you know we have no doubt that that'll
happen but we're excited to add him here
in the mix
mcdermott with his teddy kgb poker face
they're trying to show
absolutely nothing for the first like
half of that he was just like
dude he probably wants to be like wait
wait we hope
he doesn't go somewhere and start as a
starter
or something like that because that
means josh allen got hurt
and he got to play and do something like
that that's probably where he's a little
bit like i don't agree with all those
don't jinx it yeah don't jinx it uh one
year 2.5 million though oh how the
mighty have fallen it was a four-year 29
million dollar fully guaranteed contract
for trubisky four years ago
the idea that that's the is that the
best he could do
chris the guy went to the playoffs twice
and i know there were issues
but two and a half million i'm a little
sick this nfl to play quarterback
and to clearly be a backup i'm stunned
i'm stunned that that's what happened
with trubisky i am too but
you know apparently that's probably part
of the reason why they were excited to
take them wait you'll play here for this
kind of money
let's do that you know and from mr
trubisky standpoint
listen it makes a lot of sense for both
sides here it it does
and not that this is going to
necessarily you know propel mitchell
tribrisky going to be a starter
somewhere
yeah he's going to have to have that
opportunity there's no doubt about it
and it's not like the saints and drew
brees where you go well drew might be
retiring in front of us here in the next
year or two let me sign on
no but at the very least if you're
trying to be that guy
you're a backup who is you know a
low-level starter in the nfl which
mitchell trubisky is
who cares about the money at this point
it's not about the money
it's about the bigger picture he's made
a little money like you mentioned
it's not huge money but it's good enough
and you just got to now put yourself in
the best position to succeed
and he looks at that and goes wait they
got a good offense brian dayball
very creative i like what they do there
okay wait if i do get in there all right
there's pretty good support system
around me
offensive line that can protect some
receivers that can get open
that makes sense and then as we saw last
year
josh allen plays a dangerous brand of
football
it's one of those where you and me go oh
i wish he'd stop doing that a little bit
because we like watching you we don't
want you to get hurt
not every play has to be the last play
of the game and from that standpoint it
makes sense for him to sign there too
because you know with the way allen
plays there's a chance he could sprain
an ankle and be out two three weeks
something like that so
it makes sense for trubisky and the
bills of course are a super bowl team
right
and it makes sense for them to have
protection with a guy that's at least
been there done that
as far as the playoffs are concerned and
and that explains the discomfort of a
guy like sean mcdermott he doesn't want
to think about
needing mitchell trubisky and if you're
josh allen and they bring in mitchell
trubisky
you don't want to think about why
trubisky's there either he's there
not to compete with you or supplant you
he's there in the event that you get
hurt
and you can't play and we need to have
someone better than matt barkley
on the depth chart and a scale of one to
ten in the brian day ball offense how
comfortable would you be with trubisky
if alan goes out one to ten well like
i'll just say like you know six seven
ish
maybe six ish i'll say i'll say six
that's really where i'd be
yeah i'd like to see a little bit of
evidence there but the one thing this is
where i feel good about it
and maybe this is where i would feel
seven like i just think about
josh allen two years ago and the offense
they ran
in 2019 which is a little bit more of
managed josh allen
they ran him more there was a little
more trickeration within their offense
and they had a lot of trick plays last
year they do
so from that standpoint that's where i
think
you know it could work like day ball
will work around trubisky's okay yeah
he's not the
bullseye you know dead eye thrower that
josh allen is but they're
also going to look at it and go wait
he's got talent he's got
some pop in his arm and they're going to
try to work on the mechanical things to
make him more
surgical as a drop back passer but i
think they also look at it and go wait
he's a good athlete
and we can do a lot of different stuff
with him the other way too
to make it work and i think that's where
it makes sense in their eyes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports